how do you look at the web 3 stuff the
uh kind of crypto bitcoin just all of
this stuff that i think people are very
excited about right now uh given the
experience that you have like what what
are your takes on it i love it so you
know i've been through um you know i'm
53 so i've been to kind of web one two
and three and there's always people that
laugh that kind of don't understand
right so i remember you know i come from
the my first company was in the client
server software world right where you
had a server and a client and i remember
cloud was coming out and channel advisor
was a cloud-based company
and all these people from that old world
were like it'll never work you know i'm
going to put my data in the cloud oh
what happens when it rains you know so
there's always these naysayers and
they're they're usually way way more of
them than believers in the next
technology wave so i guess i've
conditioned myself to not believe that
stuff
so
you know the web3 stuff is really
fascinating to me because it kind of
ties into that amazon discussion where
when you have these decentralized things
that can happen
you know that self-form it it it's
fascinating to me how that you know the
the constitution
dow that was like a big eye-opener to me
the first wave of it i was kind of like
there's something here but i don't see
it right so there's all these
marketplaces that tried to
build a marketplace but on the
blockchain and it like didn't really
make any sense because it was worse than
ebay and amazon and you're kind of like
okay i see you're trying to do there but
i don't see the benefit of this thing
being out on the blockchain and then
like we had a lot of those
i'll call them craft coins
and that kind of stuff and it's kind of
like this feels a little ponzi-ish i'm
not really sure about that
but um you know nfts are one of the
first ones first use cases owe you a
thanks on that um you and uh and jason
also known as uh parabolic guy i guess
or whatever they compare block dude uh
you guys um uh had sponsored that that
painting from fuocious and i was like i
really like this and i uh got a little
carried away on an auction and ended up
buying it and uh thought i'd stretch
myself thin there and then i sold it for
like 5x 30 days later so i owe you pomp
i need to send you a beautiful baby gift
of some kind uh and uh i was like you
know this is really onto something i
collect comic book art i don't know uh
i'll get grab something
so um you guys know comic books well
there's actual art behind comic books oh
that's this is a page from a spider-man
comic book
and you know so i've been kind of in the
art world not not like van gogh's and
stuff like that but comic book art and
you know what's cool about this world is
you get the physical art but what's what
what stinks is i don't know who owned
this before me and
i you know it's hard to know the the i
happen to know this is the actual real
one but sometimes you know in 10 years
like i'll sell this and and someone's
going to maybe change his hands 20 times
maybe someone creates a copy
yeah so i love this idea of nfts of uh
you know being able to know where it's
been and look it up on the blockchain
and then i also like you know what
really stinks is this artist um
you know
he he should get the benefit of this in
my mind when i sell it you know if i
auction this off and it goes for twice
what i sold i would love for this
this artist to get part of that
but in the physical world we don't have
that but the blockchain and nfts i
really love that it solves some of these
problems with physical art
and maybe we can even marry those things
together so so nfts was like the gateway
for me where i clicked and i was like
all right this is better than the
existing thing i can kind of finally see
it and then i've been you know uh then
i've gone way way down the the rabbit
hole all right so so you've got the nft
stuff and i think that uh what's so
fascinating is uh you were maybe i'll
say uh cautiously uh optimistic in the
beginning where like you would see
things like okay like i see we were
trying to do but like i don't think
that's quite it and then obviously when
you saw the nfts that was uh uh where it
kind of clicked for you what do you
think about like bitcoin or some of the
other like larger um assets so ethereum
solana maybe like the top 10 uh on the
uh on like a coin market cap do you pay
attention at all to like protocols layer
ones do you think bitcoin and kind of
inflation conversation how do you think
about all that i do i love it so
the thing that's magical to me about
bitcoin is how it aligns incentives um
you know like you guys i see you guys
talk about some of the government
policies and the people that must create
government policies must have never you
know had an employee done a sales comp
plan they don't understand incentives
they're like oh we're going to put all
these people here and they're going to
be happy and live together and then
they're shocked when it doesn't work out
that way so what i love about um you
know the the you know bitcoin and then
the subsequent coins is how they really
think through the incentives and you
know um and you know what's going to
happen as the scarcity kicks in
um and and that kind of thing because it
also ties into my hobby of economics
right so so that's interesting um i will
say bitcoin didn't 100 click for me
until i read jason's book um
you know uh you know the bitcoin you
can't screw with
yeah yeah money you know hard money you
can't screw you can't bleep with um and
that one you know that one that one kind
of really resonated with me so in my
mind i kind of think of that as a
currency
store value that bitcoin specifically
and you know right now i recommend
people you know with inflation running
kind of rampant that's a really good
hedge so i kind of think of it as an
asset allocation and i've never been a
gold investor so to me and i've heard
you guys talk about this it replaces
gold as that kind of a thing um and then
ethereum is is where most of the nfts
live so so that's really been more of
where and i love this idea as a comp sci
guy that the contract is kind of baked
in there right and that's pretty
fascinating that you can have now you
can effectively have this this currency
and the way of buying things where a
little contract is baked in there and
that can do different things
and even even programmatically change
the digital asset as you go
so that's pretty fascinating um and then
you know uh
so those are the two i spent the most
time on and some of the salon and that
stuff so so you know the proof of work
and those things
i don't 100 understand the environmental
argument because
to me like if i order a product from
amazon
you know there's no way to know but i
bet you burn more
co2 than if you did a bitcoin
transaction like if i ordered you know
these airpods or something um so so i
think that's just kind of like
a false narrative i don't 100 buy into
that um that whole thing about you know
bitcoin burns so much co2 i i just i'm
not a huge believer in that because we
use all this you know when i log an
opportunity in salesforce how much co2
did i burn i just can't you know as an
e-commerce guy i just kind of don't
think that transaction can possibly be
as hard as as heavy as like buying a
widget off ebay or something um
but yeah i haven't done a ton of
research on that you guys know more
about that and i know but but i do like
these new models where you know they
have different approaches and in an open
marketplace let the best one win there
should be there should be a you know a
wide variety of these things with
features and functionality and and we
see who wins